signal you have I have a question too
sir I know you just keep for Ziegler you
know how pushing for the now on
that because it's a good follow-up for
Mufti also sure if you want to add to it
please as well you know there's this
this distortion nowadays that you can
only take knowledge from a certain clark
band of scholars say for example and
this is not specific to any any
particular group in this land and this
is a notion that people had and what I
found really interesting was the you
know the hadith of every rock when the
devil came to him busy they need to
amaze of course see in the program's how
sensitive so the kohoku you know yeah he
spoke the truth and he's a liar is it
Yanni when it comes to taking knowledge
or taking even some aspects of the deal
I'm gonna be fit for there is a stake in
some aspects of the deal we find and
this is more your future we find some
were always in embody that like say
foods on holidays or something like this
or maybe she ate of DNA on something
other to what extent bearing all of this
in mind is it allowable in Islam to take
knowledge from someone who's not from
let's say you know a man sorry question
very important question I think it's
similar to what you mentioned it in a
bit yesterday on the atheists saying
that I have no faith everything in
scientific everything is empirical so on
and so on and so forth and you said
that's not true but you do have faith in
many things many views and opinions and
principles you've accepted without doing
your own specific research so I think
this same rationale has to be used
against these people say you can't take
from this one because he has a haha it's
like mathematics and you mention that as
well
1+1 2 + 2 so on and so forth ok
the Soloff this is there this would they
say totally unanimously agreed that
nothing is taken from anyone who's a
move tell you try it is that absolutely
true we're not gonna get into it right
now is that true fill joomla castle k
theory as a theory okay say this next
step you've made a mistake not a bit you
made a hop up but we
like the copper interpreter step number
three is we'll add miss Kelly ma we
can't hear half of what you're saying
plug the ears so therefore you made a
mistake you don't sit with these
brothers you don't like the scholar this
kind of one from you and that equals we
avoid our bid R and then equals Kevin
Kevin Kevin sorry no problem alright no
problem but that's not absolutely true
rather there are many people that you do
take from and learn from that had
innovations weather will move teddy ah
we're innovators let alone COO father
okay some years ago they were saying and
I want to mention no names but they were
saying you can't take from an unknown
translator or his B translator and
there's a difference you know move today
and I saw avatar and saw hip dis and
there are these exotic terms to play
games with the people but what about the
dictionary that you read Webster Merriam
dictionary is that whoever wrote that
dictionary what about the compass what
about the Almanac what about this but
winning games it's letting books yet how
many things we use on a daily basis that
were written Michael Farr that
determines when you pray that determines
what direction in which you pray that
determines so many other things when
your child reaches puberty what does the
ruling on take it from those people you
go in at without any discernment you
take it why because the information is
clearly
saddled so if that's the sort of
catheter from that bad luck we'll be
Muslim what do they matter Muslim so so
so regardless of getting into the
details in a fight with them because
they're gonna bring this this blah
blah let's just be realistic how many
people do you take from that said all
types of horrendous things a lot of laws
are attributes his name's Sahaba and
then this goes on whether it's and this
goes on and this goes on okay so I think
that um the people have to be stopped in
their hypocrisy and don't get into the
game of the proof and evidence because
they're gonna have they have a bag full
of tricks Deborah come all the times fr
you bring a thought that's not what's
meant you bring your statement mascota
we only take Cory Anderson then you
bring them Corey Anderson
we only take what scholars say you can't
win you can't win and if you beat them
intellectually with the lead then
they'll just call you a bad name as a
chef is called to have said man never to
are Lehman in Louisville up to i never
debated what a scholar i said that i
beat them
any pride just I was undefeated well man
another woman ever in general irrelevant
and I never debated with a fool accepted
the fool beat me and that's because
fools don't take science but they take
they give info so you beat the debate
you defeat me onto his V and you're a
motor cabin hero motor low when and what
to set it in all the words and exotic
terms so you have know for sure you
cannot beat them and again you could
Quran Sunnah they bring scholar you
quote scholar Quran and Sunnah you Coker
Anderson in a scholar or he's not a big
scholar you can't win so just stop them
in their hypocrisy you guys cut it out
if we can't take nothing from an
innovator then get rid of this book and
get out of that book and don't take from
this person and this mistake and that
mistake and so on and so forth once you
burn half of the Islamic library and
then that's it then talk about taking
from us horrible bitter and so on us
over then we can talk you have to purge
your system of hypocrisy you're not
keeping it real you take for many people
that are clear innovators or innovations
and there's no difference between a book
between no wee-bey hockey even hundreds
no difference whether they're dead or
live we're not supposed to take anything
unless it's 100% dead alive in a book or
not period so stop the hypocrisy let's
stop once you get rid of the democracy
then let's sit down Lena - now Josh
let's debate on helia Jews is it
permissible to take from an innovator
not at all a burden who made a mistake a
sheikh who made a mistake no iMovie
Teddy let's look at the hardcore daniil
from the Quran Sunnah
from bihari like you mentioned from
amman muslims book in my mama's looks
elected to the hardcore I did Allah and
we did this some months back we read
from a barrage of scream and shout into
the Timothy Abadi Mohammed taken from
Macavity taken from the more J take from
this person and they gave no response
they gave no response we mentioned our
proofs our Mossad did it will cause a
man Muslim that would hold narrate it a
she he jailed and this one and that we
mentioned all the names and it gave no
response because they can't give a
response because they hypocritical
they're immature knowledge their hasty
if it's a refutation everyone will come
and listen you open up saying Bacardi
and read only a few people will come so
my advice and of course
being from Philadelphia Yanni they're
the cronies of the people from the UK
their Stoops
reality the ship most of these people
who engage in this you find that they
have not exceeded the elementary level
of no no never got past ed Rumia sudafed
ethic they haven't got passed by Konya
these are the people who are either like
I said either saying from from the son
of down man it goes wrong I was wrong
until today Mufti is wrong he's a Mook
Teddy he's an innovator it's the same
methodology amongst people is that you
start learning a few letters and now you
are the Imam of Jakarta Dean everyone's
wrong you are right and in reality they
have not passed the elementary level of
knowledge and I give them an excuse in
that we actually all kind of went
through that these type of phases were
in the beginning we thought we knew and
for sure and then the more you learn the
more you realize how flexible is famous
and the rich tradition that we have and
the various legal and Theological and
you know various opinions logical
opinions and various Sciences that are
just as valid just as strong and
everyone has their position and their
evidences for their position and you get
to respect that and you become much more
laid-back much more mellow and you
realize that I'm not going to speak
cause I don't have no